لن يكون هناك سلام دائم اذا انتصر المعتدي
لذلك افضل سبل للوصول لحل سلمه هي دعم
اوكرانيا
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم على واقعي معارك محتدمه
وقصف مكثف بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
في خرسون ودنيا
الاتهامات بشان استهداف المدنيين في حين
اكد الامين العام للنيتو ان الحلفه سلم
اوكرانيا ما يمكرها من التصدي للمسيرات
ولن يتراجع عن دعمها
الاسرائيلي وحزب العظمه اليهوديه في مسار
تشكيل الحكومه الاتفاق يقضي بتولي بني
كثير حقيبه الامن الداخليه مع صلاحيه تشمل
اداره شرطه حارس الحدود في الضفه الغربيه
في المقابل حذر وزير الدفاع من الاتفاق
وقال انه يشكل خطرا امنيا على اسرائيل
يحضر الترويجا للمثليه الجنسيه وتغيير
الجنس عبر الاعلانات والاعلام والمواد
المنشوره عبر الانترنت والكتب والافلام
حيث ستعاقب السلطات المخالفين غرامات
تتراوح بين 100,000 وخمسه ملايين ربا
التغريدات على تويتر تسجل رقما قياسيا في
تاريخ المنصه في التزامني مع مونديال قطر
حيث اعلن المدير التنفيذي لتويتر لهم ماسك
عن احصائيه غير مسبوقه للتغريدات
المتفاعله مع مواجهتك كاس العالم ونتائجها
واجواء المونديال في الدوحه وصلت الى
20,000 تغريده في الثانيه الى اللقاء